[Music]
and you're watching I'd like to know our
Bible question and answer program here
at Secret Unsealed and Some TV. Thank
you for sharing just a little bit of
your no doubt busy day with us and uh it
is our prayer that you will be edified
and encouraged and informed as we sit
together and study these things from the
word of God. Your questions, our
answers. My name is CA Murray and I'm in
the company of Pastor Steven Boore and
Pastor David Salazar and uh we exist to
answer your questions and we have a
great time doing so. If you would like
to send a question in, we encourage you
to do so by sending your question to
tvsumtv.org.
That's tv at some su m as in marytv.org.
And we will get to your questions just
as quickly as we possibly can. And we
thank you in advance for your Bible
questions uh because it gives us a
chance to do something we love to do and
that's study the word of God. Pastor
Boore, would you launch out in prayer as
we begin our questions for this day?
>> Father in heaven, we come before you
with humility of heart
because we realize that we know so
little.
>> We know just enough to get us from point
A to point B, from earth to heaven. But
meanwhile, we have many questions.
Questions that have been sent to us by
those who watch this program. I ask Lord
that you will give us your strength and
your wisdom to answer these questions
according to your word.
>> Amen.
>> And that the answers might be a blessing
to those who regularly tune in to this
program.
We claim the promise of your presence
and your wisdom in the precious and holy
name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Thank you for that bit of
humility. We don't have all the answers,
>> but the Bible does and God does.
>> Amen. and we just seek to transmit those
to our our viewing public and we we
thank you for that.
>> Our first question comes from Sonia uh
uh in Florida and um she says,
"Greetings, pastors. I recently watched
an ad for the 2025 National Eukaristic
Congress whose focus is on Jesus family
unity along with unifying with others to
enhance peaceful relationships.
They are also encouraging those who have
no church affiliation and are seeking
Jesus to attend the congress congress
rather. Uh the question how does this
eukaristic congress fit into last day
prophecy?
>> Well uh first of all this congress this
national eucharistic congress that our
friends sonia is uh mentioning was
actually a uh an event that already
passed was from July 17 to July 21
um in Indianapolis to Los Angeles. It
was a it was a event that was aimed at
that. And so um this this this
congress rather it's one that it's aimed
at revival or getting people more
involved in the doctrine of the
Eucharist. So it's trying to bring
people to understand or participate or
have more devotion to the Eucharist.
Nevertheless, um the concept here that
is more important that you know the way
that they're trying to advertise this
event is about family, about Jesus,
inviting people to become involved to
become part of this movement. And so in
a certain way, uh those things seem very
appealing and very good. They appear to
be, you know, wholesome, trying to bring
people into a more of a harmony, unity.
But honestly the power behind these type
of events this type of assemblies it's
again one of deception one of uh
bringing people to embrace a false
doctrine such as theorist doctrine which
is the concept of the sub trans uh
substantiation I think it is called
>> transubstantiation
>> transation thank you transubstantiation
sorry about that yes which is obviously
as we know it's a a mistake to believe
that the body of Jesus is actually
becomes the actual element in that wine
and the bread that the uh priest uh
blesses or what not. So this is are
again false doctrines with uh a sort of
a cover of of goodness in them. But
again in initially or in in the core of
it is really a poisonous idea of trying
to get people away from God's word and
into understanding or believing
something that is false as as as the
many of the Catholic countries are are
there.
I think that
when you base anything on a false
doctrine, a false premise, it it cannot
come out right because the the
foundation that it's built upon is is
not true. the idea that through the Holy
Spirit and the instrumentality of the
priest
um the wine and the bread actually
become a a part of uh of of of Christ of
the real Christ is not biblically you
can't support that from the word of God.
>> So any
group of people who come together under
the veneer of family and unity with a
false premise it it it cannot be right.
Um, one of the things about coming
together, uh, is if we look at the
history of of coming together, it's it's
like let's not let's not worry so much
about doctrines. Let's just kind of come
to Jesus, sing kumbaya, and just come
together. You you believe that, we'll
suspend that. You believe that, we'll
suspend that. Let's just let's come
together. But if your your identity is
your belief is your doctrinal package.
So if you suspend your doctrinal
package, who are you? You know, we are
Seventh Day Adventists because we
believe in the Sabbath. We believe in
the second coming of Jesus Christ. If we
hide that under a bushel, we have no
identity.
>> So you are what you teach, you are what
you preach, you are what you believe.
And if you you put that in your back
pocket, then you you're nothing really.
So the Bible tells us uh we we've got to
be true to ourselves. You know the last
part of the three of those messages says
come out. Well, why are you coming out?
Because what you are a part of is not
real. It's not true. It's not biblical.
So, you've got to separate yourself from
that and stand up for the word of God.
So, anything that is based on a false
premise cannot be real. Cannot be
supported by the Bible. And I believe we
cannot as as honest true Christians be a
part of it.
The bottom line is uh the word eukarist
>> that already that already basically
tells everyone what this is all about.
>> Yes.
>> You know, they could have said uh just
family or unity of Christians, you know,
but they put in the word Eucharist.
It was the it was the dream of the last
three popes that someday all Christians
will gather together to celebrate the
eukarist.
Because basically the idea is if all
Christians come together like the
apostle Paul says to celebrate the
eukarist then there's going to be unity
among all Christians. But the problem is
as as both of you mentioned is the the
Roman Catholic idea of the eukarist.
Mhm.
>> The the eukarist is when people go to
what we call the Lord's supper.
>> And basically, uh, Catholics believe
that they're really partaking of the
flesh of Christ when they partake of
that host.
>> Mhm.
>> By the way, it's not even bread.
>> Yeah.
>> It's a host that melts in your mouth.
>> Yes.
>> You're not supposed to chew it because
how are you going to chew on Christ?
That that's basically the idea. and the
and the wine which the priest drinks
which is not given to the lay people um
supposedly becomes the real blood of
Christ.
>> Mhm.
>> It's called transubstantiation.
>> Yes.
>> We know that that's not biblical at all.
>> Of course not.
>> You know, it's a magical view
>> of the bread
>> and and and the wine. Uh so why would
you want to go to a congress where it's
called a eukaristic congress
>> see an expert
>> at hiding real motivations
>> right
>> from the garden of Eden.
>> Yes.
>> You know he come he uses camouflage
>> you know he he appears like a beautiful
serpent. The most beautiful animal
according to Ellen White
>> in the garden
>> and the wisest of all. That's why we're
supposed to be wise as serpents. And and
so and he says to Eve, you know, if you
eat from the tree, you're going to be
super wise. You're going to be blessed.
But beneath that was deception.
>> Ellen White's description of the papacy
is the best description I've ever read
anywhere.
Behind the variable appearance of the
chameleon
is the invariable venom of the serpent.
M
>> so Satan will take something that
appears good
>> and it really isn't good.
>> Yeah.
>> Because the end result and the
motivation is wrong.
>> So I would not foresee any Adventist
going to a Eucharistic congress to
promote family unity, marital unity, or
unity in the church. M
>> it simply does not make any sense
whatsoever because we know that this
system is the antichrist of scripture.
And I know that that's not a popular
saying thing to say in a program like
this that goes to the whole world and
different kinds of people. But I
encourage everyone do your research. Do
your historical research.
>> Do your research in the Bible with
prayer asking for the guidance of the
Holy Spirit. And you'll see that it's
very dangerous to place yourself in an
environment such as this.
>> Amen. The you know the question she even
asked our friend Sonia in the in regards
to how this congress fits into the last
day prophecies. Well, it specifically
doesn't, but remember that it does. It's
part of what the Bible speaks of in
Revelation 14a, for example, how that
Babylon has fallen and has made all
nations drink of the wine of her wrath
of her own fornication. And also in
Revelation 17, it speaks of how the the
the you know, the the kings of the earth
have drunk of her wine. In other words,
through throughout the world, many
people are being deceived through the
false doctrines of this power, which
you, Pastor Boy, you mentioned really
clearly. It's the antichrist of of the
of the Bible is is the last power that
it's, you know, the the masterpiece of
Satan to deceive the world. And so as it
its influence is being bigger, becoming
stronger and more open and embraced by
thousands of Christians, thousands of
Protestants in a way and and around the
world people see the what the Catholic
Church is doing as a as as as wholesome,
as wonderful, as something to emulate.
We are seeing that fulfillment of
prophecy. So yes, all these things can
give you a sense of the work that has
been done in becoming that power that
infiltrates and makes everyone except
those who are studying the scriptures to
take on that wine of the fornication,
that wine of false doctrine. You know,
the the world that we now live in, the
world that we inhabited, we inhabit is
so fractured,
so torn apart that anything that
promises some kind of sanity,
>> some kind of unity, people are are
grasping for because they're they're
just the world is so insane.
>> Yeah.
>> And and Satan can seize on that
desperation. Mhm.
>> Um uh the Catholic Church says, "Okay,
well, many churches, we just sing about
Catholic church. We can give you a
recipe to give you sanity in an insane
world."
>> Well, I'm going to move to that because
I don't have anything else. I don't have
anything better,
>> right?
>> So, I'm going to I'm going to when the
the Pope came to Panama, uh we were
there together.
>> Um and we passed out
thousands tens of thousands of
literature. Nobody threw anything away.
>> Nobody dropped anything to the ground.
You know, sometimes you pass a letter
chair and somebody
>> Yeah.
>> throws it over their shoulder. But no,
they they were listening, looking,
begging for something truthful.
>> And and one of the things that the pope
said, well, let's let's let's reaffirm
Sunday. Same message, family,
>> unity,
>> youth,
>> youth coming together. and and Panama as
a as as a country was flooded with
youth. I mean, youth came from all over
the world.
>> Uh it was it was amazing to see. Um so,
anything that that that promises
something better than what we have to
live with every day, people are going to
flock to. But but the thing is, we are
told to to buy truth and sell it not.
>> Seek truth. Uh not just some fantasy.
So, we've got to we've got to deal with
truth. And of course you mentioned it,
you mentioned, I mentioned it. The the
back end of the three enders message
says come out of Babylon. Come out of
confusion. Jettison that stuff that is
not real. Because though it it seems
like it's going to satisfy, ultimately
it will not.
>> Satan is an expert at giving people plus
Hebrews.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Indeed. Sugar pills and
not anything that can really cure the
sin problem. So good question. Sonia
from Florida and uh we hope that we've
done it justice in our answers. We got
time to squeeze in just one more. Uh
this one is from New York City. All
right. U
W A Y A W. Yaw. Um I'm not sure how to
pronounce it. Y A W from New York City.
And uh we praise the Lord for for Yaw.
Hope I'm not butchering that name. Um uh
I came across a text in Matthew chapter
10 which I've been struggling to
understand.
When they persecute you in this city,
flee to another. For assuredly I say to
you, you will not have gone through the
cities of Israel before the come before
the son of man comes. That's Matthew
10:23. What did Jesus mean in the last
part of the verse when he said, "You
will not have gone through the cities of
Israel before the son of man come?" Are
we to take the second part of this verse
literally? How can I answer a friend who
thinks this verse was an error in
translation? Thank you in advance for
your unwavering support. Uh, all right,
let's wrestle with this just a little
bit. We're looking at Matthew chap 10
verse 23.
>> This question or this verse is an
interesting verse as the Lord mentions
there and I'll probably better to read
it says the the verse when they
persecute you in this city flee to
another for as surely I say to you you
will not have gone through the cities of
Israel before the son of man comes.
Um now notice that this this city is
actually connected to or this I'm sorry
this verse is actually in reference to
the verse prior to that where it says
verse 22 and you will be hated by all
for my name's sake but he who endures to
the end will be saved. And then he goes
when they persecute you in the city flee
to another for surely I say to you you
will not have gone through the cities of
Israel before the son of man comes. So
the context of this this this
saying of Christ it's more in line with
the context of the end. Now we have to
understand that Christ was preparing the
disciples first for their experience in
Israel in their time frame. the the the
disciples were not able to um see
necessarily the the aspect of the coming
of Christ
in in 20 2,000 years or more. They
thought that this work will be done in
their lifetime. So Christ just like in
Matthew 24 we have the part where Christ
speaks of the destruction of Jerusalem
and then uses that as a reference to the
time of the end. Here Christ is is
speaking to them to their time and but
also to our time. So um the concept
there that is mentioning that we shall
be hated by by all for my name's sake
and he who endures till the end will be
saved. It's an it's is applicable to our
time as as well as it was applicable to
their experience as a nation. Now uh
going back to the verse that that that
person has a question with
uh the the command is very simple since
you are going to be persecuted you're
going to receive direction by the people
that are in your area or in your in your
country in the nation of Israel as you
are faithfully doing my work you come to
a city they they throw you away from
that one go to the next and continue
through that experience all the way till
the And
because uh that is the duty of of our
our disciples. So likewise today we are
this I think more applicable to us in
the sense that we are to understand that
we have to go through every city and the
world is is huge. So there's you know
there is no way that we can say the
whole world has been reached the whole
world has been done. God is telling us
you have to go through every city uh as
much as you can before the son of man
comes. And so I think that it's it's a
it's a it's a two-wave application. One
for the time of Jesus and one for our
time today. And again, the idea is we
have to continue to faithfully wor uh
worship and share the gospel to others.
>> Uh the bottom line is that what is being
used here is what I call a generic you
>> in harmony with what you're saying.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh let me give you a couple of examples
of this. Um the great commission in
Matthew chapter 28
uh verse 18 says 'And and Jesus came and
spoke to them saying all authority has
been given to me in heaven and on earth.
Go therefore and make disciples of all
nations baptizing them in the name of
the Father and of the Son and of the
Holy Spirit, teaching them to observe
all things that I have commanded you.
>> And lo, I am with you always, even to
the end of the age. Does that mean that
they were going to be alive when Jesus
comes?
>> They were going to be alive between when
Jesus left and when Jesus comes. No,
it's See, when he says you,
>> Mhm.
>> he's saying all believers
>> are supposed to go out and make
disciples. So the you is a generic you.
It includes much more.
>> One other example, John 14. The word you
is used repeatedly. Let not your heart
be troubled. He's speaking to the to the
disciples. Mhm.
>> You believe in God, believe also in me.
In my father's house are many mansions.
If it were not so, I would have told
you. I go to prepare a place for you.
And if I go and prepare a place for you,
I will come again and receive you to
myself. So, he's not going to receive
anyone except them. Right.
>> No, it's a generic you.
>> Indeed.
>> So, is the gospel going to go to all the
cities of Israel before the second
coming of Christ? Yes. But it's not
necessarily that little group. You
>> the U is universal or generic.
>> Sometimes you means you. You pastor. You
pastor. Sometimes you means y'all.
>> Yes.
>> You know uh and and that's particularly
in that John 14. Uh that you is y'all.
All y'all. You know from now until the
end of time.
>> You haven't you have not spoken of as as
a Texan. So you're from New York.
>> I borrow that.
I did go to college at at Oakland in
Huntsville, Alabama. A lot of y'all down
there. So you you is y'all. Um um I I I
see this as a call uh the Matthew 10 as
a call to evangelism.
>> Absolutely.
>> Right.
>> Not for just those but evangelism till
the day Christ returns. Right.
>> It is a universal call to those sitting
in front of him and to the world that is
called to stand up for Jesus. And
another thing maybe just a little side
note that we have to remember is that if
you were to take this text just let's
say just literally speaking
uh let's remember that the disciples 12
disciples well 11 after Judas was uh you
know betrayed Jesus but the disciples
were to be to start in Jerusalem Judea
just Samaria and the whole world as the
gospel called but interestingly enough
not all the disciples iples lived long
enough to do that work themselves. So
even if we were to take this literally
it actually was in a sense fulfilled uh
you know not everyone
we got to go through every city in
Israel uh you know James was killed
before early on in the history of the
Christian church. So before Jesus came
they already had some of them have been
lost on the way. I mean before would
come rather you know. So the this in a
sense this verse became fulfilled to a
certain degree in that experience of the
disciples that were speaking of but
again that's just if you try to make it
really really you know just use it
literally there but and and as an
understanding as we have shared is
really more of a command for all his
disciples to follow.
>> Amen.
>> Praise the Lord. I'm looking at the
clock on the wall. We can try to squeeze
this one in or I think our time would
better be spent. Uh pastor, if you would
just promo your pieces just once again
because they are very very particularly
the one on the state of the dead just
impresses me. That's something that the
Christian church needs to have and needs
to study and needs to understand.
misinterpreted texts on the state of the
dead. Very important this time of
history where spiritualism is growing by
leaps and bounds in the United States
and in the world. And I also want to
take this opportunity to thank everyone
who supports this ministry.
>> Amen.
>> Um primarily through your prayers but
also supports it financially. It takes
significant resources, financial
resources to produce these programs. It
requires much personnel. and requires
much equipment and we greatly appreciate
those who not only watch our programs
but also contribute so that we may
continue to produce programs that will
bless those who are watching and prepare
people for the second coming of Christ.
So, I encourage you to continue to pray
without ceasing for what we do. And if
you're able uh to send us a donation uh
that will help us continue presenting
these programs which are very important
for this day and age.
>> Amen. And when you send a word of
encouragement that our programs bless
you, you have little you can little know
how much that encourages us as we come
together each and every day to do the
work of God. Thank you. God bless. We'll
see you again soon.
[Music]